back here at home helping communities  during the pandemic  that's the goal from of a group of  volunteers who gather today  to help those who need it most the  southwest regional council of carpenters  is helping remodel kitchens and  bathrooms  for homeless veterans living at veterans  village the founder of share village  says each of the units sees a lot of  wear and tear so this help is crucial  these men and women are geared up  this is the union that helps build las  vegas and to help our veterans  like today is priceless to us because  it's very expensive to have this kind of  work done  especially now when corporate giving and  individual giving is way down  this is a this is a big lift up to us  veterans village is helping homeless  veterans all year long  if you'd like to donate you can go to  their website at  sharevillagelasvegas.org